Do you ever feel like leaving you
problems behind, strapping on your arm
cannon and going on an adventure
to jump around on top of stuff and
blast away at evil robots?
I know, right?
Me too.
Welcome to our second course on
2D game development with Lib GDX.
In the first course, we made
a simple game of dodging icicles.
In this course, we'll learn how to
make a much more complex platformer
game featuring our hero, Giga Gal.
In the first three levels, you'll let
Giga Gal walk around, including this
cool walk animation, and you'll let
her jump around on top of platforms.
Giga Gal will jump around on
the top of platforms, dodging and
fighting enemies with bullets
fired out of her arm cannon.
Sounds pretty cool, huh?
So what do we need to do
to bring Giga Gal to life?
This course has eight levels to beat.
In this level,
you'll learn how to draw the images and
animations that make
up Giga Gal's world.
In the next levels, we'll add the logic
for Giga Gal herself, the platforms, and
the camera that follows
Giga Gal around the game world.
In the second half of the course,
we will add the evil robot enemies, and
let Giga Gal fight back with her cannon.
Finally, we will learn to load
level data, and add a HUD and
on-screen controls.
By the way, this course relies heavily
on the content from our first course on
2D game development with Lib GDX,
so if you haven't already,
you'll definitely want to take
that course before moving on.